européen vincent ledoux si monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse au
premier ministre lors du sommet
afrique-france le président de la
république déclare avoir pour l'afrique
des sentiments intenses au cours de son
quinquennat il aura d'ailleurs visité 32
fois mais quelle fut la politique
africaine de monsieur hollande avant
tout sécuritaire et on ne saurait le lui
reprocher l'attentat-suicide de gao nous
en rappelle la nécessité et nous pouvons
adresser ici un message d'amitié au
peuple malien
on ne saurait le lui reprocher si
toutefois la courbe de l'aide publique
au développement on avait connu le même
sort que celle du chômage faisant ainsi
mentir son 57e grand engagement mois
président j'agirai pour une aide accrue
aux pays en développement
or sous son mandat l'aide aux pays
subsahariens aura chuté de 20%
serge mikaïloff pose la question
l'afrique en crise va-t-elle se
retrouver dans nos banlieues
il n'a pas de mots assez durs pour dire
combien le gouvernement à abandonner les
pays les plus pauvres alors que c'est là
où se trouvent les plus graves risques
géopolitiques risques et opportunités
pour le chef de l'état
l'afrique est notre avenir il a raison
une classe moyenne 250 à 300 millions de
consommateurs une urbanisation galopante
un marché du mobile et du e-commerce en
explosion mais que n'at-il fait
justement pour que la france cesse de
perdre du terrain dans toute l'afrique
subsaharienne au profit des pays
émergents comme la chine
il nous a manqué un grand plan une
formidable énergie pour promouvoir
l'afrique comme relais de croissance
accompagnez nos pmi pme sont des marchés
qui nécessitent connaissance et
préparation à travers un contrat gagnant
gagnant
ce qui se fait en afrique a les
conséquences pour toute l'europe et donc
pour la france martèle françois hollande
les chiffes le fond pourtant mentir à
l'aune d'un mandat qui porte une
politique africaine en demi teinte au
mali il annonce même son 61e et dernier
engagement
23 milliards d'euros pour l'afrique pour
ces cinq prochaines années décidément le
zèbre ne se défait pas de ses brûlures
ma question est simple comment pensez
vous monsieur le premier ministre
abonder le fonds d'investissement pour
l'afrique annoncé à bamako alors que les
budgets n'ont cessé de baisser
comment allez-vous utiliser vos derniers
jours pour donner à la politique
africaine
la pleine mesure qui devait être la
sienne la balle est à monsieur jean marc
ayrault ministre des affaires étrangères
et du développement international
président monsieur le député vous vous
venez sans doute oublié que
la loi de finances qui a été voté
récemment par le parlement je ne suis
pas qu'ici vous l'avez voter je ne le
pense pas a vu que le led publique au
développement avaient augmenté de façon
substantielle à la fois l'initiative de
mon ministère et du travail qu'a fait
andré vallini que je remercie et puis
aussi des initiatives prises par les
députés et parlementaires eux-mêmes que
je remercie aussi ce qui fait que le
niveau de notre aide au développement
qui avait effectivement baissé depuis
2010 à remonter et dépasse celui que
nous avons trouvé en 2012
et vous avez vous même citer un chiffre
le président de la république à bamako a
confirmé que l'aide à l'afrique à les
atteindre avec l' agence française de
développement 23 milliards dans les cinq
prochaines années et avec une partie
consacrée à la transition énergétique
qui est effectivement un effort
considérable
je ne voudrais pas qu'on oublie non plus
dans cette aide au développement la
partie européenne de cette aide au
développement qui est très conséquente à
l'échelle internationale concernant
l'aide à l'afrique et j'appuie en
permanence en ce sens c'est l'europe qui
apporte la plus grande aide
avec notre propre contribution puisque
nous sommes le deuxième contributeur au
niveau de l'union européenne donc nous
avons devant nous ce défi considérable
et qui a été évoquée à au sommet de
bamako dans un esprit je dirais de
partenariat équitable sincère
respectueux de l'indépendance des
africains et qui est celui de la
sécurité des pays africains de leur
donner les moyens d'apporter d'assurer
leur propre sécurité de ne pas le faire
leur place même s'il l'avons fait dans
l'urgence mais aussi de permettre à
l'afrique de se développer de donner aux
sociétés civiles qui ont une énergie
extraordinaire car la force de l'afrique
c'est sa jeunesse
les chances de se développer et lorsque
nous sommes réunis à bamako
c'est à toute l'afrique que nous nous
sommes adressés pas seulement l'afrique
francophone d'afrique de l'ouest et tous
les pays étaient là au plus haut niveau
et je dois vous dire que c'était
impressionnant y compris toutes les
langues officielles parlées en afrique
qui ont été repris à cliquer à ce sommet
et il a été rendu hommage à l'action de
françois hollande est de la france
depuis près de cinq ans et je ne te
crois vraiment vous pouvoir vous dire
que cet hommage était non seulement
chaleureux mais il était profondément
sincère parce qu'il correspond aussi à
la réalité
ce que nous avons entrepris s'est jamais
assez c'est vrai mais je crois que nous
pouvons quand même être fiers de ce qui
a été fait parce que la françafrique qui
est finie